in the instance of illness or other
health related matters affecting a
participant's ability to participate in
the game they must withdraw yeah the
camp situation was tough tonight how
would you have handled it I think the
show handle it right I think they handle
it right because we certainly don't know
who was actually going home tonight it
could have been Kim going home tonight
and would it have been fair to not let
her to for her not to dance and then
still come back next week and then
someone else go home that wouldn't have
been fair so we don't know what the
outcome was um but if the rules say you
can't go the next week if you don't
perform and truly is unfortunate that
she wasn't able to make it here to
perform but I remember my season when I
hurt my back and I said to myself I
don't care what happens I'm gonna go on
that dance floor I'm gonna walk on to
that dance floor and whatever happens
happens I wanted to like go get on a bus
and bring her here time and I'm time
that bus takes you long